Vincent Oshana.
Ladies and gentlemen,
come on now.
Thank you.
Thank you, guys, thank you.
I've known Vincent
for quite some time,
and I think the
ongoing joke we have
is the Hollywood handshake.
Hollywood.
Hollywood-- the [inaudible].
They act like they know.
It's like, God bless you.
I haven't seen you
in so long, dude.
Boy, hey.
- I hope y'all doing good.
- All right.
- So good to see you, man.
- Yeah.
So good to see you.
The more famous you
get, the less effort
you put into shaking a hand.
Yeah.
How long you been
doing stand-up, man?
- Seriously, for about 10 years.
- 10 years.
I just-- I left the
military to literally
come here and just
do this, because I
love making people laugh.
Were you that guy
in the military?
I was that guy
in the military.
I got in trouble on the
first day on the milita--
For what?
I was-- me and my boy Jamal
joined at the same time.
And I was-- you know what
I'm saying, like, just--
I was dancing.
And one of the
instructors caught me,
made me come stand
in the middle--
because we're all
in our underwear.
They're just making sure
we have no weapons--
the first day of the military.
So he made me stand in
a circle of 100 dudes.
And he's like start
dancing right now.
And I was like-- he's,
like, don't-- just go.
So I'm--
[laughter]
And I'm running
out of stuff to do.
He's like, do other--
do other things.
So picture me.
I'm doing this one.
And he tells my boys, he's
like, and you cheer him on.
So picture me dancing like this
and my boys going, go Vinny!
Go Vinny!
So that was on the first
day, so I knew that I was
going to get kicked out soon.
No, obviously not
the place to be funny.
VINCENT OSHANA: They
don't like that.
Yeah, they get a
little pissed off
at funny guys in the military.
VINCENT OSHANA: Yeah.
Were those the people
who influenced you?
Were those the people that'd
say, yo, you got to try it,
Vinny.
You're funny as hell.
Yeah, well, the
real inspiration
was my mom, because
growing up she was
the funniest one in our family.
Did you have your mom's
support from day one?
From day one-- well,
you know how mothers are.
They're like, you're going to
go there and there's drugs.
And I was like--
[laughter]
I was like, yeah.
And she's like, just be smart.
And no, she's awesome.
She's my biggest fan.
Number one, number one fan.
VINCENT OSHANA: Number one fan.
No, you can't get
better than that.
Yeah.
Let's look at some
early pictures of my guy.
[cat-calling]
Yeah, yeah.
My first impression was what
the [bleep] is going on.
[laughter]
Yo, the dude, the guy
that took this was obviously
trying to have sex with me.
KEVIN HART: Yes, yes.
And he was like, just
undress me with your eyes.
And I go, I thought
it was the camera.
He's like, no, no, no--
me.
Keep going.
He was naked.
At the end of the
shoot, he was naked.
And I got no clothes
on under here.
I'm like, this.
I love it.
This is a comedy head shot.
This is for comedy.
All right, we've
got our nice guy.
He's a very, very funny guy.
Let's take a look at him
and they show you this.
You go--